it's no secret that Europe's populist
and nationalist parties are gearing up
to try and make a splash at the coming
European elections but who's helping
them my guest this week here in Brussels
is Michelle Beaudry kamon a corporate
lawyer who's working with president
Trump's former strategist Steve Bannon
to try and coordinate those party's
activities their aim they say is to
drive a stake through the heart of the
Brussels vampire but what does that
really mean
[Music]
we shall not recommend welcome to
conflict zone thank you I pleasure to be
here nobody is more identified with the
populist nationalist movement than
Donald Trump a man who's known as in
many cases a serial liar do you share
his contempt for the truth not at all I
don't think that he is a liar I think
he's a big disrupter I see he's indeed
in conflict was the establishment is in
conflict with the press and I don't
believe he's alive I don't you don't
know so he lied from day one in the
White House about the size of his
inauguration crowd do you don't think
that was a lot I was there I was there I
will largest ever crowd he said today
the largest there is from time to time
some exaggeration but it was a very
impressive
I was the exaggeration can also be a lie
he lied about consulting several former
US presidents who told him apparently
they too would have put up a wall along
the border with Mexico no such
conversations ever took place
I don't know he likes our 80 times about
bringing in the largest tax cut in US
history it wasn't if you lied about work
it was a very efficient that's good
yeah but it wasn't the largest and when
he didn't lie he himself so okay when he
didn't lie himself he peddled other
people's lies that Obama wasn't born in
the United States well there was a big
big discussion there was a discussion
they were conflict about documents and
so that's not true that's really that's
so true lies to you are just exactly
true I am very interested in truth but I
can tell you as a lawyer I know all
things can be can be presented you know
there's this saying that only lawyers
and and painters can turn black into Y
so in politics it happens to end up with
the press it up so you turn truth into a
sort of shaky
this is politics this is politics and
politics it's not everybody u.s. fact
we're facts you have convictions and on
top of that I mean with all the parties
can come with exaggeration can come with
approximation this is rhetoric you know
this is rhetoric but real that's real
that's not true when we when we measure
said when when when we mentioned trouble
icing is a big disrupter that's one
thing and secondly he has to be assessed
he has to be judged by the results and
his results are both standing so as long
as you can lie your head off Perez knows
the economy is doing well it doesn't
matter it's not only the economy he
defeated Isis he moves the well well it
changed politics
indeed it changed politics you know
Steve panel up in your friend and
colleague has been already open about
the benefits of dishonesty hasn't he
especially when he told the journalist
Michael Lewis the real opposition is the
media and the way you deal with them is
to fill the zone with crap I've cleaned
up that last word slightly but that's
what he said in other words lies and
nonsense fill the zone with lies but
first of all he has been he has been
confronted mr. Trump by by a torrent of
Lies since the first day of his
inauguration and even before so he is
hitting back he's eating a back at the
press in detail using lies with lies not
setting an example I I don't think you
can just you know put the light on Trump
under the forms of lies and so on these
politics and look again look at the
results mr. McMahon do you seriously
think then you say you care about
democracy that you can have a credible
democracy where the most powerful head
of state in the world looks his own
people in the eye and lies to them
repeatedly and government employees are
forced to lie as well so as not to call
him out okay again you you asked me here
to discuss about
populism in European pop he's your
figurehead in the one where I'm
configure is one of the most important
guy indeed on the on the world politics
we get your play on the world scene and
I want to tell you more I supported him
from almost day one week one if you look
at my videos in support that I made and
so on and I still fully support him of
course
yes this exaggeration is you know it's
character is what it is but I look at
the result and you need you need such a
personality to bring in the changes that
were necessary and that all the
president prior to him weren't able to
make and I want to tell you there's an
odd thing that he is doing is just
sticking to his promises is delivering
one after one is promises and the last
one I didn't do so far is the wall and
is prepared to go very far to get this
mess another one he didn't do as well
he promised because because he's
frustrated cause is blocked by the
Democrats
no he isn't
no no I'm not talking about I'm talking
about the world I'm talking about the
other promise that he didn't deliver it
doesn't the Elector is citizen do not
care about his tax return you chose his
promises I'm telling you the promise a
BD is electors one was the wall and it
wasn't able to deliver and he's prepared
to go on the fight and what he's doing
right now to get it done true that's
that's a man of achievement he's not
sticking to his promise they're May 20th
2014 if I decide to run for office
reduce my who cares deliver on returns
of the president they care about its
policies clearly
when Steve Palin says he wants to
replace failed and corrupt political
establishment what's he gonna replace
them with a bunch of even bigger liars
because that's what it looked like
doesn't it he's going to replace we want
to replace them
everywhere in the world where people are
really care for the ordinary guy this is
the key this is the case of Trump it's
the case for Porto Naru this is the case
for second Brazil in Brazil is the case
for urban and they care for their people
and by the way the other people show
them exactly that they support them
fully that's it that's the result you
want to replace a corrupt political
establishment if you look at how Trump
is replacing his corrupt two corrupt
political establishment if there was one
before him he's replaced it with a lot
of people five of them like during the
confirmation hearings this is that a
recommendation the kind of people that
get brought in to replace a corrupt
political establishment everywhere I am
NOT here you know to discuss you know
any action of the Trump and Miss but you
I can't I can't I can't I can tell you
from my own experience here okay I won't
discuss because I'm not in charge of the
Trump administration but I can tell you
from my own experience in Belgium in
Wallonia in the small country with this
interview take place that indeed the
establishment the particular
establishment is corrupt that indeed
it's a kind of mafia system that had
been set up that have been set up okay
that was my that was my porn at all but
I am Telling You in a different look I
am telling you that this is my
experience here and this is exactly what
we want to do here also in Europe
wherever it's possible talk about what
you want to do in Europe are you not
bothered by the rise of neo-nazi groups
and white supremacists in America since
Donald Trump came to pocket you're not
worried that if you bring populist to
power in Europe you're going to have
exactly the same kind of thing first of
all you know as a Jew okay I am NOT
concerned by the right-wing populism and
visibly the intolerance and vis a vie de
like the why why I want I want to tell
you why I want to tell you why because
today people like Trump people like
bolzen ro people like salvini
okay people like myself of course and
people like Steve Bannon are very close
to the interest of the Jewish population
that comes our Jewish population and
very close to Israel and if you asked me
today what is my main concern in Europe
it's not this movement it's Jeremy
Corbyn eventually getting into power in
England this is Mike on there are plenty
of Jewish groups in America that were
very concerned about Charlottesville the
kind of open anti-semitism that was on
show there in 2017 where anti-fascists
clashed with white supremacists and yes
and it is and this is true and and I
want to tell you that this is true what
they say that were bad people on both
sides and I can tell you that we I
despise I despised ban on despise this
fringe group is this fascist and
populist book but fascism is on both
sides I know you maybe don't know them
but I know the antifa they are the same
fascist than those from the right body
of Orthodox rabbis in the u.s. condemned
Trump's comparisons between white
supremacists sound of protesters they
accuse them of a failure of moral
leadership and Fanning the flames of
intolerance and chauvinism but they know
nothing according to you no no
unfortunately I know too well the
American Jewry which is largely so you
can dem members we are know that largely
for for tens of years in support of the
Democrat they are supporting heavily
Obama and you know I know that only a
minority of American Jew support Trump
but I know that it's very positive
yeah largely I know it's just as me I
know them very well just I have a lot of
meetings with them I know exactly where
they are McAndrew stands okay and the
mainstream and those and I know that
today Trump as a lot of support from the
Orthodox Jewish community in the United
States and I want to tell you the large
I know I know
I know very well Breitbart
- okay I've a lot of contacts I know who
is populating Breitbart and I know that
I would like to have a lot of bribe but
in support of the Jews and support of
Israel all over Europe that's a big
difference between the light the smear
and so on and the reality I know I do
face because Jews as well you speak as a
Jew they speak as Jews okay they are not
more qualified on myself to speak so
it's different of opinions and I fully
support from is it's one of the most
supportive American industry of the Jews
and Israel and by the way part of his
grandchildren are Jewish - okay let's
look at the requirements for joining
your club okay your club that members
should stand up to the EU and to the
liberal policies of Emmanuel macron and
angular - not this if you take a tough
line on immigration okay that's what you
want reason to read tough line really
nice all my statement okay what what are
the three or four tenets to join the
movement immigration one is sovereignty
that's a that's the first one okay
sovereignty of national states with
borders to define who is a citizen oh
and who is not a citizen because we
believe that without citizen sharing the
same value there is no democracy okay
that's one thing
secondly limiting migration this is a
demand from all over Europe and thirdly
fighting radical Islam okay that's our
our tennis the rest liberalism economic
liberalism and so on this is out of the
movement because it's we are
nationalists we are sovereigns so we
leave all our members with the own with
their own vision and principle in
respect of or what is accept this you
hear the use comfortable phrases like
it's a club meant for the exchange of
ideas from nationalist populist
movements across you're talking strategy
yeah
but for Bannon it's far more combative
than that isn't it he called it gumming
up the eu-parliament in other words
blocking your purpose is essentially
destructive isn't it no it's true Buena
building in our your breaking we are we
are we are reinforcing and rebuilding
the preeminence of national what is they
say he said the beating heart of the
globalist project is in Brussels if I
Drive the stake through the vampire the
whole thing will start anticipating
pretty self-important claims we have we
we analyze the situation in the sense
that the EU system like the UN
ultimately ends up as imperialism a kind
of imperialism and it is true that we
have to bring down this kind of MP on a
[ __ ] the largest trading this doesn't
mean that we want to bring them totally
you want at least to be reformed if it
could be reformed it has to be - it has
to be indeed abandon this project why
it's been in the member countries for
years listen for years the the fighting
against that ok so if we have to swim
again sometime let's swim ok this is not
a problem if if you think that you are
right this is nonsense
listen they look at the situation right
now
yet this project ok and this project as
I say becomes more and more a kind of
imperialist now as far as it was
technically teased and so on nobody
really care we're happy to to live
within within this EU front framework
but the moment that they decide you
should get in and get out of Europe they
decide they want to impose to the to the
Czech or the Hungarians or the Polish
who should be the neighbors you know
that in Russia or in Budapest they
should accept migrants you know Muslim
magomayev being checked and so on that
they don't want then they become real
imperialists
so they are shooting themselves and
is the Vampire Slayer that's a bit of a
stretch isn't it yeah listen
this is wasn't I asked about delusions
of grandeur is because that's pretty
much what we all know Trump said about
Steve ban and didn't he when after Steve
ban and lost his White House job he lost
his mind said Donald Trump he spent his
time in the White House leaking false
information to make him seem more
important than he was
it's the only thing he does well okay
that's the view on his former strategist
I I have heard that listen you two are
trying to be more important than you
actually are
listen you are here you have to come and
interview me I did I didn't ask you to
come so I'm the wretched Oh so so yeah
so let's come back with with with with
Steve okay Steve was within the populist
movement before Trump okay from 2009
same year that I enter into politics by
the way it was with Breitbart okay and
yes there's an ideology there is a
vision okay and it could exercise or put
in practice his vision with tram for a
certain time until they crash indeed a
kind of ego clash for sure and so on but
there was a Steven before Tron Wistrom
and there's a Steve Allen after Trump to
believe me and this is the vision being
indeed brought to other countries and
then the US and and embodied in Italy by
material some years later of the leaked
party why because of his strong attitude
to immigration no is hardline you know
this is attitude but then I want to tell
you a the racism that goes with are
there is no race in there you heard what
some things have been saying listen
about black people there there is no
racism in any parties any parties from
left to right to Center you will always
meet extremists
statement I can tell you I can show you
cartoons made by a socialist guy MP
here in Brussels and now and cartoons
that remind us you know the thirties
about the Jews and I can tell you it's
not because there's some MPs that
they're having such attitude that I
believe that the Socialist Party in
Belgica mr. magic I mean you can have
racist statements but let me look
normally they're condemned here they let
me believe he has not condemned racist
statements against for instance a
politician like seokkyun gay member of
the European Parliament and the Italy's
first black government minister you want
to know the kind of things they said
about her when I see mr. Quillan gay I'm
unable not to think about although I
don't say that it is the appearance the
of an orangutan that was from a league
senator on 2013 and meantime the first
Italian senator at this black is from
the leg ok
he's from the [ __ ] as you certainly
know but I want to come back I want to
tell you I want to tell you one thing
one thing about about salvini what is
important why did it become an icon you
know on the on the scene European scene
as one because of action because is so
again like Trump did that whenever you
are in power you can't change things
everybody said we can't stop the
migrants getting in and so on and
suddenly say we are blocking the
harbor's nobody will get in anymore and
the reason that they 80 or 90 percent
less of our immigration it that is full
they cannot accept them anymore
it's action and that's why is in an icon
and that's why he has been one of the
first person we asked to join and he
accepted at that time and and quite a
few people haven't accepted that
Germany's right wing aft one of the most
successful population artis in Europe
they sent you off empty hand
alexander garland said Europe isn't
America the interests of the
anti-establishment parties in Europe are
quite divergent as the banner will not
succeed in forging an alliance of the
like-minded for the European elections
same with Miller Semin okay Czech
president and we didn't want to either
Club is a worldwide club it is true that
the first battleground or the first
battleground will be will be Europe
where the battle is being conducted now
I want to tell you I'm afraid that your
information I a bit outdated you know
for one very important thing it's true
that Golan came with with this statement
because they didn't know exactly what
was the movement but I can tell you
meantime we have so many meetings from
people with AFD it's a question of time
before they will come officially to the
meeting mean that there is not that's a
good sales technique no no it's only
about it's only a matter of time you
don't know you know what he turned you
down flat didn't he who is middle semen
the problem Czech president the problem
is that it focused immediately on a
totally different issue from from Europe
and sovereign Esmond poverty it focused
I mean the meeting focused on the
relation with China and you know that
ban on and America are fighting hard
Chinese imperialism while some countries
like the Czech Republic being are
willing to be a port of entry for China
in Europe and that's was there was a
clash sort of vision was a classroom may
be of interest at that time and and
again there is I mean with the movement
it's a club okay and you will be people
that will get in immediately we will be
people that will exit the club and you
will be get people that will come later
I have no doubt maybe I just let's see
let's see our summit who will be there
we won't be one of the things that Steve
Palin has spoken about your movement
doing is providing assistance with
rolling and data mark micro targeting of
voters the kinds of things that this
firm Cambridge analytically used to do
when Bannon was a board member
this was the company that folded after
being accused of going way beyond
analysis and trying to rigged elections
and misuse facebook data this is a
company that boasted of using so-called
Dark Arts in trapping rival candidates
in fake bribery stings hiring
prostitutes to seduce them this was a
the next full chief executive who is on
record as actually saying this is what
the company did it's not what you intend
to do for the populist parties listen
again again use this kind of method
again the the aim of the movement is to
be a club okay and that's a fair to be a
forum where people that usually not meet
meet while you have the the global is no
meeting in the fall so just cigars and
brandy it's it is also that it is also
that because these people do not know
each other for most of the time and it's
very important that will be when we know
each other were able to help each other
secondly we said that wherever it would
be permissible and possible and wherever
there would be a demand we will be
helping by the way are you going to use
methods like no Cambridge and so far so
far that I know I mean nobody accused
Steve ban on himself to have use any
this is what the company faced up my
point to you is that your populist
movement has already in the United
States by lightening up white
supremacists and with brexit in Britain
has created enormous damage to the
social fabric it's led to bitter
political polarization because you've
been looking for people's grievances and
anger and you want to stir it up I want
I want to tell you that the biggest
damage you dangerous the biggest damage
just wait the biggest damage has been
created by the elites or the so-called
elite to the ordinary guy for the last
twenty or thirty years
look at the social fabric as it is
existing today look at the social fabric
for example in France and so on look at
at the social fabric you know in the
small English English cities for example
we are not bringing we are not bringing
damages well bring damages to the social
fabric we are bringing damages to the
elite to the establishment as it is
today's that is true and we are threat
to them and the polarization didn't
exist before really you can make it
worse no you can oh yeah we are probably
aesthetics we are too contended to
represent the ordinary guy okay that has
been so long despised and forgotten by
these elites and indeed we are we have
the populist from all over the world
the voice of this ordinary guy we're
bringing great voice and we are not we
are not putting problem on the social
permission yelled recommend thanks very
much for being on topic so okay thank
you my pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]